the North remembers we know no king but
the King in the north whose name is
stark I don't care whose have busted Ned
Stark's blood runs through his veins
he's my king from this day until his
last day the Bolton's
are defeated the war is over winter has
come
if the maesters are right it'll be the
coldest one in a thousand years we
should ride home and wait out the coming
storms the war is not over and I promise
you friend
the true enemy won't weigh out the storm
it brings the storm what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another Game
of Thrones Season eight and Game
Theory's video before I get into today's
video I just want to make a quick
announcement I have another set of the
isang of Ice and Fire books that I want
to give away to one of you if you would
like to enter your name to have a chance
on winning all five books just use the
link that is down below in the
description or comments section of the
video the winner will be randomly
selected in a few weeks so good luck to
everyone that enters now let's get into
today's discussion in this video I want
to talk about something Jon Snow said
that has made me scratch my head ever
since he said it I think there is a very
good chance this could be some of the
foreshadowing for the third big twist in
this series first let me do a quick
recap that way everyone knows exactly
what I'm referring to back in season 7
episode 6 Jon Snow led a small party
beyond the wall so they could capture a
white in hopes of bringing it south to
prove the threat beyond the wall is real
during this mission Jon Snow and company
are successful with capturing a white
but they aren't able to do it quietly
the white screams frantically which
blows their cover and ultimately leads
to them being chased and surrounded on a
frozen lake they end up being stuck on
this rock for over 24 hours but during
this time they are able to reflect on
everything that has happened during this
mission which leads to them coming to
the realization that when Jon Snow
killed the white Walker it also killed
all of the whites that were traveling in
his
party except for the one they captured
of course this leads to beric Dondarrion
suggested that if you kill the night
king then it should kill his entire army
since he was the one that turned them
all it seemed like a very reasonable
plan because they did just witness this
work on a much smaller scale with the
white Walker in the group of whites but
for some odd reason Jon Snow does not
agree with this logic and this makes me
wonder what this could mean for the
endgame let's take a look at this scene
then try to figure out what Jon Snow
actually meant by this that's another
kill him he turned them all
you know this time I think this is a
very interesting scene because that
short line of dialogue could be setting
up what actually happens with the night
king and his army at the end of the
series everyone that is standing on that
rock just saw what happened when Jon
Snow killed the white Walker so you
would think by cutting off the head of
the snake it should defeat the entire
army but why did Jon Snow say you don't
understand and why didn't Jon explain
what the hell he meant by that I have
briefly talked about this scene before
but I felt like it was time to dedicate
an entire video to this question because
I believe what Jon Snow said will be
very important next season I want to go
over a few different options that could
possibly help explain what Jon Snow
meant by this then at the end of the
video let me know what you think it
means maybe one of you have thought of
something I haven't even considered yet
that could shed some more light on to
all of this first let's start with an
easy explanation perhaps John men
exactly what he said which is Barrack
doesn't fully understand the night King
and what he is capable of Jon Snow has
been a first-hand witness to the night
Kings powers which not many characters
can say John was there when the night
king in his army attacked hardhome so he
has seen the night king raised an army
within seconds John has also fought the
night Kings army on more than one
occasion
so other than tormund Giantsbane Jon has
more experience with the army of the
Dead than any other character standing
on that rock he probably has a pretty
good idea at how hard it's gonna be to
kill the night king for good the crazy
thing is the night king probably still
has other tricks up his sleeve that have
yet to be revealed
even though Jon Snow knows nothing this
is the one thing that he is starting to
understand Jon has seen some of the
things the night king is capable of so
he has to know that killing him won't be
an easy task I mean what did beric
Dondarrion actually plan on doing do you
think he would be able to kill his way
through all those whites then challenge
the night king to one versus one combat
I don't think so the night king is not
only surrounded by thousands of whites
but he also has his own personal
Kingsguard
made up of several white walkers that
are armed with magical waste weapons on
the whites who usually just carry
anything they can find laying on the
ground
beric Dondarrion has also been spoiled
by Thoreau's of mirror you need more
than one hand to count how many times
barek has been resurrected this allows
him to enter almost any battle without
fear knowing he can be brought back to
life at any time afraid
and must be good why is that good means
you're not stupid
now that Thoris of Mira's dead
you would think beric Dondarrion would
start to take this into consideration by
being more cautious with his approach
another option I would like to entertain
is perhaps John knows more than we think
how many seasons have we been hearing
people tell John he knows nothing he
Girt said this to John all the time then
in season 5 Melisandre said the same
thing you know nothing Jon Snow you know
nothing Jon Snow you know nothing Jon
Snow
[Music]
you know nothing Jon Snow
[Music]
he has had encounters what the dead ever
since the first season so perhaps he
knows something we don't
not only that but I have always believed
the Starks and the others are connected
most likely through blood which I have
went over in multiple videos so it won't
go down that road again but most of you
should know what I mean
if you've seen some of my other videos
on that topic also John Snow is the one
who found all those cave paintings on
Dragonstone could John have seen
something that helped him understand a
little more about the night king that
has not been revealed to us yet maybe or
maybe not if you think about it Game of
Thrones has really been hitting us over
the head with the heavy-handed
foreshadowing in exposition over the
last two seasons especially when it
comes to Daenerys Targaryen being able
to have children so I finally kind of
weird that John would say something this
vague without following it up with any
kind of explanation as to what he meant
by you don't understand lately the
writers have had no problem was spoon
feeding information to the audience but
they chose not to do it this time and I
personally think it could be hinting at
just how powerful the night king truly
is I know I have said this many times
before but I highly doubt they will be
able to kill the night king with
dragonglass or Valyrian steel and I
think Jon Snow might be starting to
sense this as well he already knows how
to kill whites and White Walkers but he
obviously knows there is something very
special about the night King John knows
beric Dondarrion splaying sounds way too
simple there must be some kind of a
twist when it comes to killing the night
king and or stopping his entire army and
once let me know your thoughts on all of
this do you think Jon Snow still knows
nothing or is he keeping his cards close
to his chest
why did Jon tell beric Dondarrion he did
not understand let me know what you
think put your thoughts down below in
the comment section if you want to enter
the giveaway make sure to use the link
down below in the description of the
video or check the comment section
because I will pin it at the top thank
you all very much for stopping by and
watching the video I appreciate that as
always and thank you to everyone on
patreon for supporting my channel if you
are a patreon supporter of mine and you
entered my other giveaway on patreon
make sure you check the page later to
find out who won all seven seasons of
Game of Thrones
thanks again I hope everyone has a great
day I will see you very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]